qui est ici simon moore est marié père
de quatre enfants
mais surtout premier adjoint au maire de
saint-joseph durant deux mandatures très
impliqué dans la vie associative en
martinique selon dans la campagne
électorale en vue des prochains mais si
pâle de saint-joseph d'une décision
prise à l'issue de l'annnonce du métal
jaune rose qui aurait déclaré au dernier
conseil municipal qu'il ne briguera pas
un troisième mandat
j'attends la jeanne rose avait dès les
débuts il avait laissé entendre malgré
tout qu'il ferait trois mandats et je le
dis comme cela il me semble mais malgré
tout vous savez que il ya eu quelques a
fait quelque 6,3 aurait pu qu'il est un
peu chagriné je le dis comme ça mais en
fait c'est un homme je louerai le jour à
l'occasion de les dire qui a fait
beaucoup beaucoup poussé jours pour
suivre les grands chantiers en cours et
trouver les fonds nécessaires à la
réalisation de nouveaux projets est
l'ambition de cet homme de terrain il ya
certes un certain nombre de projets
quand j'ai commencé que j'ai mis en
oeuvre et que je voudrais poursuivre il
ya des projets à court terme ans et j'ai
vraiment envie de vous suivre
il ya des projets à moyen terme et
projet que je devais développer lors des
causes estadi de réunion que je ferai
avec la population mais en fait je pense
réellement que de perdre mon esprit a
cédé par le fait que j'ai été à côté du
maire que je connais parfaitement la
commune et je sais exactement me
semble-t-il ce qu'il faut faire pour
améliorer le cadre ev devine
au certain joseph à l'expérience du
candidat est un atout non négligeable à
prendre en compte avant le passage à
l'isoloir
à la place les districts de natation des
fois le mais absent donc c'est lui et
je lève la fonction de 4e bien également
donc il connaît très bien le boulot
qu'il fait et même temps beau être amer
c'est pas donné à n'importe qui il faut
être maintenant soit un ancien maire
soit premier ou deuxième adjoint pour
être la mère de la semaine
il connaît les dossiers donc ce qu'est
prête et réseaux vous souhaitez pas été
fait pendant cette mandature
jacques roth qui pourrait alors
continuer en 2020 avec toute l'équipe à
qui l'on a autour d'elle absent de cette
présentation de candidature le maire à
thann ans jeanne rose que nous avons
contacté ce matin par téléphone précise
qu'il ne fait pour le moment aucune
déclaration
simon morin devra donc eu convainc parmi
les sept autres candidats les électeurs
de cette commune de saint-joseph
[Applaudissements]